deja este lugar mejor de como lo
encontraste nos decía mi mamá cada vez
que íbamos de día de campo al río
y si estaba sucio nos pedía primero que
todo recoger la basura y luego si patos
al agua
tengo tantos recuerdos de cuando mis
papás nos enseñaron el respeto a la
naturaleza mi mamá y sus plantas nos
decía
mira que ya flor ya vista que ellos
retoños wow ese árbol va a dar muchos
frutos este año y mi papá siempre listo
con el asador para sembrar esta y
aquella planta y así pasó el tiempo y
pasaron los años
hasta el día en que decidí salir de
mexico con un plan perfecto en mano ese
plan era ir a londres por un año
aprender todo lo que tenía que aprender
y regresar a mexico para transformar
y bueno como los planes perfectos
siempre son tan perfectos este año muy
pronto se convirtió en 20 años 20 años
donde me llevaron a lugares
que me reforzaron esa apreciación hacia
el medio ambiente por ejemplo en londres
pues el verano dura muy poco
y cuando sale el sol es todo un evento
la gente sale de sus trabajos de sus
oficinas de sus casas y se van a los
parques
en busca de un poquito de sol la verdad
aquí entre nos
al principio me parecían tan exagerados
pero bueno el tiempo me enseñó a que no
eran tan exageradas
y no tarde mucho en unirme a ese gentil
en busca de un poquito de sol
es increíble como pues siendo de este
lugar tan maravillosamente caluroso
nunca pensé como el sol pudiera tener
tal efecto en mi alma
después de londres me mudé a singapur
en singapur me acuerdo
que un día estaba totalmente estresada
tenía muchas tensiones del trabajo y no
sé por qué se me ocurrió quitarme los
zapatos
pues decidí salir a caminar un poquito
al jardín
me acerqué a un árbol y me acuerdo que
cuando hice estas raíces
sentí como este árbol absorbía todo mi
estrés hasta me sentía como que más
ligera
es una sensación que nunca se me va a
olvidar es más
hasta tengo mi árbol favorito
y así
con experiencias vivencias muchos
aprendizajes y después de 20 años
regresé a mi hogar aquí en este bello
pueblo mágico de santiago en realidad mi
regreso fue en respuesta a un llamado
interior que me invitaba a reconectar me
con mi familia con mis raíces por una
parte
híjole sabía que iba a ser muy padre
reconectarme con mi familia y ese
reencuentro
por otra parte sabía que eso
significaría un gran cambio para mí
dicen que los grandes cambios siempre
vienen con una fuerte sacudida
y sí
mi mamá
cayó gravemente enferma
y falleció a los pocos meses de mi
regreso
fue ahí donde comencé una fuerte lucha
interior
me sentía totalmente fuera del lugar en
un lugar donde solo quedaban pedacitos
me sentía ridícula por aquel plan
perfecto que algún día pensé tener
pero bueno la vida ya se había encargado
de enseñarme que cuando uno toca fondo
no se puede y no se debe de quedar mucho
tiempo ahí entonces pues poco a poco fui
recogiendo esos pedacitos
mi hogar fue mi refugio y con mi papá
fuimos restaurando ese jardín
en todos sus sentidos
como parte de esta restauración yo
comencé a ser bueno sucedieron dos cosas
que les quiero compartir
por una parte yo comencé a hacer
pequeñas acciones para el cuidado del
medio ambiente entonces cuando voy al
mercadito pues buscó a identifico al
señor de los productos locales me llevo
mis bolsas reutilizables y cuando voy a
caminar recojo la basura que me
encuentro
también he ido armando mi kit de rescate
con la intención de reducir el uso de
plástico entonces cuando voy a un
restaurante o una reunión donde veo que
están usando desechables
pues yo ahí despistadamente pues saco mi
plato y aquí que pues que me sirvan los
taquitos de chicharrón y digo por si
acaso sirven frijoles a la tierra que me
encanta para llevar y bueno nunca olvido
mis cubiertos este está súper cool
porque
doble cuando yo estaba platicando con mi
hermana marlene
coincidimos en que estas pequeñas
acciones se pueden convertir en un
efecto multiplicador si más personas se
suman
entonces pues con la intención de poner
a disposición más productos alternos al
plástico y para el cuidado del medio
ambiente fue que iniciamos casa game una
asociación civil
en casa gamer ofrecemos talleres de
concientización para niños y para
jóvenes
y también organizamos brigadas de
limpieza aquí en el municipio de
santiago ofrecemos productos alternos al
plástico y también alimentos sanos
fíjense lo que pasó con el tiempo fuimos
viendo que hay personas que se quieren
sumar y con mucho entusiasmo pero como
que no se atreven a hacerlo solas
entonces vimos la necesidad de iniciar
un proyecto comunitario por eso a
finales de marzo vamos a empezar un
huerto comunitario para bueno pues que
ofrezca alimentos sanos frescos y sin
químicos
para que este huerto sea sustentable
estamos ahorita trabajando en la
instalación de un sistema de riego de un
sistema de recolección de agua de lluvia
y un sistema de riego eficiente
el otro proyecto es un gallinero
y así las familias que se sumen podrán
recibir la proporción de lo que se
produzca en el gallinero
y así con pequeñas acciones juntas en
comunidad en pro de nuestro planeta
fíjense a través del tiempo y al paso
del tiempo nos hemos también dado cuenta
que cuando estamos a punto de tirar la
toalla
siempre aparece alguien que nos recuerda
la razón de ser
y que nos inyecta con energía para
continuar como ala
alan es uno de los niños que asisten a
los talleres que ofrecemos en uno de los
talleres le regalamos un costal para que
ellos lo de coren se lo apropien lo
lleven a su casa y hagan un poco de
reciclado un dia alancito toca la puerta
de mi casa y me enseña su costal lleno
de botellas pero que el recogió
y digo wow pues a dejarlo allí en el
porche yo luego lo llevó al centro de
reciclaje
alancito me dijo no yo quiero mi costal
de regreso porque quiero seguir
recogiendo botellas en la casa y luego
me dice hay muchas botellas tiradas en
todos lados
claro vacíe el costal en un contenedor y
le regrese alancito su costal para que
continuara con su ahora labor
fue muy emocionante ver cómo
como alan pudo adoptar estos hábitos por
una parte recoge la noticia basura y por
otra parte la recoge cuando tiene
oportunidad
en su libro el poder de los hábitos
charles week nos comparte que un hábito
tiene tres elementos
la señal la rutina y la recompensa y
esto lo explica con un ejemplo
dice que a principios del siglo 20
a principios del siglo 20 students una
pasta dental
le agrego ácido cítrico a la pasta para
dar esa sensación de frescura en la boca
al final del cepillado
y así la gente comenzó a creer que el
producto pues estaba haciendo que su
boca fuese limpia
y así fue que la gente empezó a desear
esa frescura
la señal porque la asociaba con la
limpieza la recompensa y fue así que el
cepillado se hizo un hábito lo más
increíble es que esto no hace que la
pasta sea más eficaz pero convence a
quien la utiliza que el producto está
haciendo su trabajo un ejemplo más
las grandes empresas claro que han
identificado que vivimos una vida bien
acelerada y que queremos todo rápido
práctico cómodo es por eso que
desarrollaron el concepto de desechables
para que en vez de lavar pues tiremos
los platos
fue así como la gente comenzó a desear
esa practicidad comodidad la señal
porque la asociada con más tiempo y
menos esfuerzo
la recompensa fíjense y fue así como el
uso de desechables se convirtió en un
hábito
a pesar de que un desechable de duro
tiene una vida útil de 20 minutos
mientras que tarda entre 150 y 400 años
en degradarse
otro ejemplo la industria textil la
industria textil buscaba que la gente
comprará ropa de manera de manera
continua no sólo cuando la necesitara
en el favor
y bueno fue así como desarrollaron el
concepto de moda rápida
y la gente comenzaba a desear sentirse a
la moda
porque lo relacionaban con las y los
modelos de las revistas
y fue así como se iniciaron las compras
rápidas y las compras continuas a pesar
de que la industria textil es
responsable del 20 por ciento de tóxicos
que se vierten en el agua para hacer una
camisa
se necesitan 4 mil 100 litros de agua
que la organización mundial de la salud
dice que una persona necesita entre 50 y
100 litros de agua para cubrir todas sus
necesidades y evitar cualquier amenaza
de salud
pero la gran tragedia es que al día de
hoy hay millones y millones y millones
de personas que no tienen acceso a este
líquido vital
y así
nos podemos pasar la tarde revisando
ejemplos de estas grandes empresas que
nos están haciendo creer y nosotros nos
la estamos creyendo nos están vendiendo
soluciones que son redituables para ello
pero devastadoras para el medio ambiente
es por eso que el día de hoy yo te
quiero invitar a ti a ti
y a todos a que se unan al reto que
hasta gamer y se atreva a tomar tres
acciones
número 1
arma tu kit de rescate y atrévete a
dejar el uso de desechables tal vez al
principio se te hagan extrañas esas
caras de incredulidad cuando saques tu
platito para que te sirvan tus taquitos
pero te lo aseguro cuando lo conviertas
en un hábito hasta divertido se te va a
hacer número 2 recogen la basura recoge
la basura cuando vayas a caminar mira no
sólo te mantienes fit pero también dejas
tu camino limpio
y número 3 por supuesto acerca de la
naturaleza y abraza un árbol mira si te
da vergüenza abrazarlo como
despistadamente es más te reto a que
elijas tu árbol favorito quien quite y
un día hasta te quite todo el estrés del
día
hagamos que santiago se convierta en el
pueblo mágico más limpio de mexico y un
ejemplo a nivel internacional por su
estrategia para el cuidado del medio
ambiente
y claro como decía a mi mamá deja este
lugar mejor de como lo encontraste
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]